humor hiking's our sense of survival and
preserves our sanity these are the words
of Charlie Chaplin
so are these written over 30 years ago
we think too much and feel too little
more than machinery we need humanity
more than cleverness we need kindness
and gentleness without those qualities
life will be violent and all will be
lost
humor and humanity the abiding elements
of Chaplin's artistic conscience and his
unparalleled talent as actor writer
director producer composer and the quote
WC Fields the greatest ballet dancer
that ever lived
Chaplin made more people laugh than
anyone in history yet always just
beneath the hilarity were the fears and
sorrows of every man so that one book
about him is aptly titled Charlie
Chaplin king of tragedy he created an
immortal character The Little [ __ ]
a thousand writers have woven allegories
around him here's our Chaplin described
in a [ __ ] a gentleman poet a dreamer a
lonely fellow always hopeful of romance
and adventure he would have you believe
he is a scientist a musician a Duke a
polo player however he's not above
robbing a baby of its candy and of
course the occasion warrants it he will
kick a lady in the rear but only in
extreme anger the world responded not
only to the wondrous humor of the Little
[ __ ] but also to the love and
indomitable 'ti he represents to Chaplin
soaring theme that man's humanity to man
is greater than his inhumanity the
inscription reads to Charles Chaplin for
the incalculable effect he has had in
making motion pictures the art form of
this century Chaplin has become more
than a name
it is a word in the vocabulary of films
and anyone who has ever seen a movie is
in his debt
a few years ago mr. Chaplin said my only
enemy is time we respectfully disagree
for wherever and whenever there is
communication a screen and an audience
whether here on earth and now or in some
unfathomable future on some faraway star
time is Charlie Chaplin's dearest an
eternal friend
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's heavy
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
for me and words seem so futile so
feeble I can only say that thank you for
the honor of inviting me here and your
wonderful sweet people thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]